歡迎回來召華
我們今天的大來賓
是讓我覺得
在整個政權業
這樣會不會得罪人
我覺得最有型的董事長
是
OK 這個
有 這個有緣起來
就是他每次來
都會帶來滿滿的資料
跟未來的展望
所以我們今天
就真的話不多說
因為他今天準備的資料量
讓我們覺得
一定要讓他好好地講清楚來
時間多留給他
好 今天來的是
富邦投顧的董事長陳奕光 光哥
召好愛倫 各位觀眾大家好
好 真的又請到你了
因為上一次你來
是睽違了非常非常久
我們現在有進步了
我們現在隔了一季光哥
越來越短
他們之後能不能一個禮拜一次這樣
我每次來你節目這個壓力很大
因為那個資料要準備滿久
不會 因為富邦投顧在光哥的帶領下
也有自己的節目
現在的訂閱量也很高
想要看光哥也可以優先到
富邦投顧的YouTube平台
一定要的啊 要抽50萬訂閱了喔
那光哥今天有帶來作用名
股市沒有算命 只有算力
這邊講說沒有神準
只有看得比別人早
我有幫你濃縮
沒有馬後炮啦 只有早知道
對對不對
長得比較順口
他們的算口
所以這邊的話
光哥最近在看的
台股整個產業濃縮起來的金句
我覺得要看長線啦
看趨勢 然後看基本面
不要追逐這個市場上的這種喧鬧
然後把握時代的浪潮
我覺得目前看起來
還是以長線的產業面
基本面 總經面
來看整個股市投資
我覺得會是比較
比較正確的方向
不過上一次光哥來市場
是一片歡欣鼓舞
但中間我們歷經的下沙
但是雜音都是類似的
像一樣的新聞
在當時可能是很開心
中間下沙變成利空
那現在又來了
回答呢 要幫所謂的OpenAI繼續注資
是 他希望這個AI的擁動已經能持續
但是一樣回到同樣的討論
當回答成為全世界的AI融資中心的話
我們的機會跟風險在哪邊
我們從源頭來看 到底有沒有bubble
這個我覺得 假設你確定他沒有bubble
你後面任何的回檔 其實都是一個買點
那我們從這張表可以看出來
其實
2025年這個綠色這一塊
我們叫賣產值的
我們把市家賣產就揮達啦
Intel AMD還有加台積電加起來
它Cache Infrault從1334億到3777
那買產者這些CSP大廠
從2045億直接灌到今年
可能會付的現金流
我覺得第一個我覺得
這個必須要留意就是它的現金流
我們要持續觀察它的財報裡面
所展現出來的現金流到底會不會
第二個就是
從它的這部分的一個
資本主義計畫贊他的
營收贊他資本主義計畫比
你去看一下去年跟今年的這個
整個資本主義計畫是九成跟
將近40%明年
那一般來講他的這個營收贊他
資本主義計畫是40%到50%
太高了
等於說他基本上是用
CAPEX去買他的營收
這個是我們比較擔心的
那我們覺得過去平均
差不多是20%而已
那現在來到40%到50%
就是代表他的
資本主義計畫太多
然後營收根本就根本上來
所以我們去抓了一下
他的這個平均多是以30%來看
他明年的2030年的
整個資本支付計畫到2兆
2兆美金
2兆美金的話
你用30%的這個密度去算的話
其實他要抓6.6兆
可是你去看整個這個K格來算的話
CSP大廠他的這個負荷成長率
差不多是34%來看
他到2030年的營收只有5.5兆
第二個疑慮就是
假設他的營收占
他的KPEX在3成左右
他至少要做到6.6兆營收
才有辦法不可以移分
這個是第二個我們看到的疑慮
剛剛前面那一張提到的就是說
他的Cache Outflow
這個是比較擔心的
然後這一塊第二個就是他營收站他的Cafex比
反推回來的營收到底要多少才有辦法達到他的這個純一平衡點
所以我們就去算一下他的情境式分析
我們這邊有一個比較
這個叫做雄式的這個
這個數字跟
基本還有牛式的這個數字
就是我們把
Apple's就是Average Revenue PUSER的
這部分的一個單位
年負費的這部分是150塊錢
150塊錢去估的話
其實它要2.8億才有辦法達到水利量平
那你去看OpenAI現在的訂閱數差不多
它現在的活用
就是活用的這部分的一個
訂閱差不多10億
真正負費只有6到7%
等於是6000到7000萬
617萬你現在要到2.8億的人
等於說你從今年到明年
你至少要增加
今年下半年可能要增加到5000萬
明年要到1億的這樣的訂閱人數
明年才有辦法來到損益良品
那OpenR自己對20
就是2030年這部分的一個
Target的這個Revenue來看是2800億
但是你如果這樣來算的話
其實它是有機會
在未來的2027年年底
是有機會Break even
因為如果是以2.8億的這樣的一個算法
來看的話其實是有機會
所以目前看起來我們覺得
這個bubble應該要破掉的機會比較不大
只是你必須持續觀察
我剛剛前面兩項
第一個 它的現金流
到底會不會持續轉負
然後什麼時候會轉正
這第一個
第二個就是它的營收
佔它的資本支付計畫比
那對照它的營收部分
是否能夠跟得上來
然後再加上
你要持續觀察它的訂閱數
因為你現在還是要回歸後來
到底它有沒有辦法把
買產值的這部分的一個資金
變現成他的現金流跟他的獲利數值
這個是我們看到
目前看起來我們給的結論是覺得
不會有這種bubble破裂的情況
但是要持續去觀察每一季
他的現金流跟他的這個訂閱數
那光哥我有個問題想要問你
是
就是我們現在在討論的是
CSP大廠的資本支出泡沫之間的事情
那泡沫破掉會真的比較嚴重
還是說他資本支出降下來
但是上游賣產值的人
反而營收降下來會比較嚴重
其實這個就變成說他一個順序
就是說他
我們這次假設看到他們大幅增加
資本支付計畫
導致七月份的股災
因為大家覺得說
哇 你不斷的這個投入
對 你花太多錢
你沒有辦法
這個回收
那我覺得這部分可能就會回到
這個賣產值的
他到可能到2029 2030年
這時候可能會來一個停滯
我覺得那時候可能就會反過來
可能就是CSP大廠
或是這些大語言模型廠
他的獲利數是反而是比較好
這個我覺得可能那個轉折點
會是在2028、2029的時間點
對
所以反而是在投資邏輯上面
那時候再來做一些轉換
而且我們如果有用所謂的Chill GPT
它也有在進步
所以如果明年的話
後年它會轉虧為營
好像也是一個可以接受的時間點
那如果是以剛剛我提到
就是說艾倫所問到的問題
就是說那到底我們怎麼去看
它這個bubble這個時間軸
其實我這張表就是
我們剛剛公佈完半年報
其實那個數字應該非常非常好
對
其實是令人非常驚豔的一個數字
那我們應該富邦投顧是
所有市場上裡面
孤今年數字其實是最貼近的
因為我們原先孤今年整個是6.89兆
我記得我們這個
我們在在對外公佈的時候
大家還覺得說太樂觀
因為去年只有4.51兆
可是今年公佈出來的上半年就3.6兆
3.68兆這樣的數字
其實你上下半年都是1比1的話
其實今年很容易突破7兆以上
所以你去看一下
這樣子的一個獲利數字
我們可以從今年挑戰7.5兆
這樣數字上來看的話
這是第二季2.08剛剛公佈出來的
然後第三第四季目前看起來
應該都可以維持兩兆以上
那你要主要看右邊是
這個部分的 P 乘 Q 的部分
我覺得第二季主要是
因為 P 的部分大幅的上揚
因為你 P 乘 Q 就是乘 Revenue
就是你的 Price 乘以你的數量的部分
那你去看一下這一次的這個
獲利占比當然是千億至成
方局的部分占將近 40%
然後乘投至成是 2%
可是你看記憶體
記憶體在這一塊它的這個
這個漲幅其實是非常非常大的
50到60塊
這個是其實如果是百分比QQ
55到60%
那你到第三劑第四劑
其實它的這部分的QQ是有下滑
等於說你這部分的獲利數字
可能就沒有辦法
向它的這個報價來的漲得這麼多
但是還是可以維持毛利率
像這個Gosma卷是這個記憶體
有到80幾%
其實沒有問題就是可以維持
只是說你的報價可能會
這個鬼故事就會出來
就是說因為你這個QQ
沒有像第二季來得這麼強
你看第二季漲最多的
第一個是記憶體
第二個是CCL
然後MLCC它是最整齊的
所以MLCC它在接下來
下半年的這部分的一個
一個報價的漲幅來看還是會持續
所以目前看起來
賣產值的部分
在整個獲利數字的角度上來看
其實應該是賺得不滿盆盆
第三季這邊沒有數字對不對
但看得出來柱狀體是往下的
所以這已經反映在前一陣子的修正
還是我們要注意在第三季
就是您剛剛講到的
鬼故事出來
還有可能讓台股再一波修正
我想趙華問到關鍵重點
就是第二季他有一個
匯率上面的點子
所以他有匯對的這部分
毛利率的提升這第一個
第二個就是第二季的這部分
報價其實漲的是比較多
所以第三季他公布出來的數字
可能在兩兆上下
就沒有辦法像第二季來這麼好
因為第二季從1.57跳到2.08
那這個是一次性上來
那接下來我覺得
只要能夠維持兩兆多
其實就非常非常好
因為以七連五兆
你換算成配套Ratio
明年配個七成
其實明年配到五兆的現金股息
跟股票股利的機會其實蠻大
其實這個我覺得是可以繼續做官場
是 但第四季可能就可以超越第二季
超越第二季
應該是沒有太大懸念
因為目前看起來
從這個大廠這部分給出的Galaxy
還有第四季基本上就是
2027年的這個前哨戰
台位的所謂的本夢筆
但那時候我覺得會編製一個
比較好的一個outlook
所以第四季應該會比第二季來得高
因為我們都知道骨架是先行指標
所以才會講說第三季這個情況
搞不好前陣子已經反映過了
那現在進入到第三季
而且是第三季的下半場囉
第四季甚至看明年
那光哥最注意的哪一些利機
是會支撐骨架的
我想這個我們為什麼來這個節目
因為我每次都覺得壓力很大
原因是其實我們要做數
比較不一樣的地方
其實我們剛剛從一開始的邏輯
從他的Cash Flow到營收站
他KBX比我想這是我們自己看到
就是說未來怎麼去觀察他Bubble
然後第二個就是我們再看整個
他這部分的資本支付計畫
我們這樣看
資本支付計畫領先營收
營收領先獲利
獲利帶動股價
所以當你看到
剛剛艾倫所問到
假設我資本支付計畫
減少的話我是不是股價就會下來
沒有錯
所以目前看起來
國內的資本支付計畫其實非常非常強
去看我們在2025年的時候
我們的資本支付計畫是1.03兆
那我們今年到1到5月就4959億
你如果是把它處於五再乘以12的話
今年應該是1.2兆
1.2兆的KAPEX就是它
Fundrainsing這麼多錢
它就是它從市場上募這麼多錢
它所拿出來的成數效果是3到6
3到5倍
3到5倍 1.2兆乘以3到5倍的話
它應該會有三點六照照
將近六照的這樣的營收創造出來
就像你剛剛我們一開始在
錄影之前所提到的這個
這個普發現金
其實它是會有陳述效果
所以它這個
這個Foundation下去之後
它所後面創造出來的
一到三年的這部分的營收的陳述效果
應該有在三照到六照
這麼樣的水準
這是第一個我們可以看到
這部分的所達到一個歷史新高
所產生出來的
這是好的
是
但是不好是什麼
請去看一下這兩個當對比
2016年
這是2016年對不起
這應該是2016年
對 2016年
跟去年來相比的話
這是2025年
你去看他當時的這個
combatable bump
就是我們講的可轉債的部分
是從原來23%到36%
一般來講發行
所謂的這個SPO的
這種所謂可轉債
差不多是3年
3年代表就是說
3年可以換成股票
對
但是3年期間假設你有
touch到你的這種轉換價
你也可以換
只是說真正的這個籌碼
或在三年以後
2026 2728 29
這時候量會出來
第二個你看私募
私募從原先的4%到19%
私募也是所三年
所以一般來講會做私募的人
第一個 它獲利可能不是太好
但是 但是
它是看好未來三年的整個發展方向
所以這部分的一個籌碼
可能會在什麼時候出現
會在2028 2029
會陸續籌碼會出來
因為你可以轉換成你的股票
那這部分我去算過
你用1.2兆除以現在的市值
差不多是150兆 是0.8
0.8再乘以4萬6千點的話
等於說假設我今天要
趕快要轉成所謂的股票來看的話
會影響股價的點數 400點
這個是從
第一個我們從Kapex角度去看
Levonry會創造出的
就是那個Kapex會創造出
這個營收的部分這第一個
第二個就是說
他所帶來的籌碼增加
會影響到後面的股價還有他的點數
其實也是跟最近的債券市場很像
債券市場大家不斷的供給量增加
其實根本就跟那個利率沒有關係
就是因為它不斷的發展
然後公司債的利率又比你國債的利率
來得高
我變成說我的公債利率降不下來
其實這個是一個問題
這個下次有機會針對這個債券市場
我們利率我們可以來做討論
他答應喔 不逛哥講
逛哥講
不過剛剛重上所述就是
資本支出可能到202029要注意
注意放緩的問題
還有我們國內的籌碼
現在我們國內也是有在做資本支出
但是一樣
2018、2019籌碼會出現
就是剛剛我提到
combo的bump就是
它可轉換載的部分的
SPO的時間點
差不多落在那時候
所以你這時候你在看
他們敢在這時候發載
其實它創造出來的銀色效果
會非常不錯
股價往上衝
可是你要小心
待後面它的籌碼會增加
這個可能就是
它所帶來的另外一塊
就是供給量會增加
那這一塊我覺得
我要算一個公式給我們的這個
觀眾朋友 對
我覺得這個就可以讓你知道說
現在到底有沒有泡沫
你不要再去聽這些事
好像講說這個已經發佈了
或是說一些的這種空頭總司令
他去嚇你
其實我們先來看一下
其實他現在有過熱
有過熱
你從四值處理M1跟M2
5.15跟2.25
其實是遠遠高於他的平均值
遠遠高於平均值
這個我們是事實
這個我們不能否認
其實是過熱
但是你去看他的這部分的一個配喜
配洗的話 7.5兆
我用55% 非常非常保守去算
其實2027年他就可以配到4.13兆
4.13兆你除以現在的市值
差不多是160兆的話
其實現在值率差不多2.8 2.5
不是太高
但是你是有這種cash dipton ear
這部分可以拿回來
那你如果是用6成 7成的話
那配了洗就更高了
所以這部分的資金行情
2027年其實指數不需要看單
因為你從這樣子的獲利數字去反推
你股價越跌 你的現金值率越高
其實你的股價是越跌越便宜
你反而會刺激外資去買
所以這第一個是這樣算
然後第二個在算法上來看
到底有沒有泡沫
我們剛剛算過就是今年7.5兆
去年是4.5億兆
所以應該是66%
66%的話 你再加上M1
M1差不多是4.4
4.4再減掉
市值增加差不多是61%
其實應該是差不多正8到10%的正
就是說它現在
你的那個獲利的成長
加上M1B的成長
減掉市值的增加是正的話
代表這個產業
沒有追上
對 沒有沒有沒有BOBO的情況
所以你用這樣角度去看
你就可以很清楚就是說
其實你只要確定它的獲利數字是上去的
然後M1B現在是
1到6月是4.4%
然後我們現在市值YTD是增加61%
兩個加起來減掉
其實現在差不多在8到10附近
所以就代表說其實目前看起來
再度正嚴其實沒有所謂的泡沫的問題
這個我覺得可以讓我們的觀眾
你在做你的投資其實就是懸鼓而已
不是說它這會有所謂的這種
08年或是2000年.com
那種這種所謂泡沫的危機
等於在基本面的支撐上面
產業前景的支撐上面
資金流的支撐上面
沒有這個問題
剩下就是信念跟時機點的問題
我們現在將運指數其實
以所有的全球股市來說
算厲害的也
對 其實它如果是以這個
它的這一次7月份的股災
其實集中市場它比OTC要來得強
那因為集中市場有一個
護國神山站的地方
所以它蝶幅算是
比這個其他三個市場要來得
稍微可控一些
那我們從P-Ration來看
我們用未來的這個
Forward的EPS去顧的話
其實它的P Ratio是17.4倍
那這個費辦是21.2
日本是20%
日本這麼高
對 22倍 對
你如果是這樣來看
其實台股在這個地方
用Four World的EPS去估它的P Ratio
其實算是算上的Value
但你會對照過來看說
怎麼會有一個這個5.2的
你去看一下上半年的這個
三星跟海翼式的財報
我把換上台幣
台灣剛剛是3.8兆
你知道它上半年
他這兩家公司單單賺台幣賺多少
5.8兆
他賺5.8兆
所以5.8兆你去PK一個
我們全市場賺3.8兆
一樣上半年他只有兩家公司
直接完勝你全部1980家的
上市貴公司的獲利數字
為什麼匪夷這麼低
因為大家現在還是不認同
記憶體他是一個成長股
假設他是成長股
他是用這種所謂的方具的角度來看
其實現在的
現在6000點的韓股其實是非常便宜的
但是目前看起來大家現在扭轉這樣的
格局就是
他現在簽一個叫LTA
叫Longton的這部分的這個規範
他把長約簽下去之後
綁量在綁架的過程裡面
其實他這部分會慢慢的回升上來
所以我們認為說
這兩個市場應該在3D裡面
他佔很非常非常有角色
哪3D
算力 存力跟電力
台灣這3D都有
他只有存力
他只有儲存力
所以他差不多占25%左右
那臺灣是3.0 全部囊括
所以臺灣全拿的情況之下
他的p.e ratio其實是 undervalued
但是你後面還是要觀察
這個市場再跌下去也不對
也不能太看稅他
因為他去槓桿完之後
他回歸基本面
其實應該是有走他的
基本面的路才對
他也不能太弱
因為這一波的去槓桿風暴
就是從韓國開始的
他們的本應比是跟著三星海利
是我們本應比跟著台積電
所以自然我們會稍微高一些
但還是你覺得低於正常的價值對不對
我覺得是 undervalued
因為我們目前看起來
以這個 QQ 的報價上來看
我們講說四大的存力
HBM 還有這個 DDR4  DDR5
還有 LPDDR 部分
Nanferesh SSD 的部分
其實這四個 HINES 都有
而且他獲利數字真的非常好
那我們覺得說後面
他應該是有機會回歸基本面
只是說現在開槓桿是開得有點大
好 當然這一波去槓桿
希望有人說已經去了 95%
但是我們先不管點數
有時候點數不見得反映在我們的股票
的個股上
但是展望2020剛剛聽起來
其實眾多條件的聚集是沒有大問題的
就要注意機會跟風險在哪裡
沒錯 我想在十個條件
十個利好跟十個利空
反正現在足球進入下半場
你剩下下半場這五個月
你要去檢視這一波
假設任何的這個回檔下來
你就看這個部分的利多跟利好
有沒有所變化
我們先看利多的部分
A1我們辦法全面變線
對線其實現在AI進入第三個週期
第二週期叫做算力週期
晶片週期就是算力週期
第二週期我們把它叫做基建週期
就是基礎建設的週期
第三個叫做信用週期
其實現在進入信用週期
你未來誰能夠拿最多的便宜的錢
誰就會是贏家
其實這一次為什麼揮達它能夠這樣子的
去做所謂的這個
融資的這部分的擔保人
其實因為它賺的撥滿盆滿
他是唯一能夠發動這一波AI裡面
最主要的一個角色
那我覺得這個全面對線
就是我們剛剛一開始提到
為什麼我們從這樣的邏輯下來看
就是從剛剛的我們講的
現金流的部分
然後到營收站
他的資本支付計畫的比的部分
然後再去用
阿布茲的這部分的一個算法
去算出他合理的營收應該多少
那這個部分我覺得要全面對線
這就是我們這樣來觀察
然後台積電的這部分的獲利數字
我覺得台積電是一個非常
我們講說透明度很高的
的一個公司
其實很好估
那我們覺得它的營收QOQ
每一個月
其實我們估起來都還滿順的
所以目前看起來
應該持續高成長
然後台灣GDP已經不用講了
因為我們
已經把2026的第三第四季
跟2027年1234季的
單季的GDP都告訴你了
主技術他講得非常清楚
今年11點多 明年6點多
然後明年是先下後上
今年是先上後下
所以這個部分我覺得是持續高成長
利率率我覺得是重點
我覺得現在大家有一個誤解
就是常常保挖許當作是一個鷹派
不是嗎
我這樣子看
我自己內部看法
我覺得今年最差最差就是
不升不降
好一點應該要降起
為什麼
因為你去看他今年稻奇的債券有十兆
然後今年稻奇的債券有十兆
戒心環就的過程裡面
他利率再往上升的話
其實他的這個債券的
他的這個所謂的財政資質
會大幅的增加
所以我們覺得第一個
他是沒有這樣的一個條件
第二個就是說
你去看他的Finnip許縣兩條線
包括Infraction跟他的Job Report部分
目前看起來已經Soft 已經轉下來
所以目前看起來
我覺得他是比較沒有這樣的一個條件
去做所謂的升息的動作
那不升息那頂多就是Bed On Change
那On Change的話
假設他的這部分兩個數字有稍微下來的話
可能他這部分還要再做一些降息
好 因為這邊的觀察
當然是我們都知道
川普或者說英文國的財政來說
絕對是希望降息
但是瓦許他可能要維持一個檯面上
在通紅抗爭上面的一個立場
所以他就變成說他回到
回到他的這個論調裡面
叫Merma指數
之前上次有來講
就是說他講話越少的
這部分的聯準會主席
其實波動是比較低的
我覺得他有點失成
當時葉倫的這樣的一個情況
那檯壁的部分
我覺得31.24年限
他只要能夠深迫的話
這波行情應該是不容小序
但是因根果是
外資買鈔檯壁升值
不是台幣升值外資買超
因果要先搞清楚
所以這個台幣升值的部分
就要看外資的買賣超
因為目前看起來
E2對M1.4兆
所以這是事實
所以台幣要持續升值
ETF我覺得要聊一下就是
ETF我覺得會是後面的
主要的一個雪球效應
現在的ETF是要10.17兆
那其中有7.5兆是被動式的
主動式是8800億
然後另外傳統式的MUCHO放
是1.78兆加起來10兆
我去算一下9到12月份預計發行的
這部分的基金有4000到5000億
所以這部分應該是有機會再捲進來
然後散戶全部回歸是看融資維持率
現在融資維持率有回到200
當初48218的當時的融資維持率
維持率是在208
那假設他這個部分又回到208以上
其實這個部分的這個
這種所謂的氣氛上來看
我覺得就是比較不錯的
那這個部分就是
其他就是低原政治
這邊可以做參考
那這個部分可能就是比較負面
要留意
ETF採踏這可能要小心
再來一次 我們上次也有討論過這件事
可是這是還好啊
還好 對 因為我覺得
台灣的股民其實比
比韓國股股民其實
我們有經驗 數字比
我們是 我們有經驗
新一層也是數字比較強
那這個就是評價了
台股市值的這部分泡沫
現在差不多四百多
那我們就要去看說
但是說到底現在的這個市值
我們假如到160兆的話
台股就公務萬年
是
現在是150
我現在講集中市場
所以這幾個我覺得就是
把它當作是
你在這一波
有任何的回檔
你就把它拿出來看一下
到底有沒有打勾
有打勾
那你就要稍微去做一些
檢詞你這部分的一個部位
那最後的話
因為拜年班剛剛崩不完
我們又很快速的幫大家
review一下
這個第四季的投資策略
或者是說
整個半年報告的成績
光哥總點評一下
我想在整個數字上來看
我們一直對這個
EPS的這部分預測跟獲利的預測
其實我們非常非常的注重
所以在整體來看
你去看這一次的這個
上半年的這部分財寶3.65兆
成長116% 將近
那其中比較好的就是這兩個
一個是半導體
一個是金融
金融業
其實金融業我其實是蠻看好
因為其實大家把金融業當作是
傳統產業其實不對
其實金融業也是AI
因為你去類AI的部分
就是說他事實上是跟AI是綁在一起的
不管他投資部門
他有投資AI的這部分的股票
或者是說他跟他企業這部分的
生意往來也有跟AI
其實他算是一個AI
等於說他是語錄均衝
只是說他是比較末端
所以在這一次的這個獲利數字來看的話
其實他的這個成長幅度是蠻大的
所以我覺得在這兩塊
我們是覺得在
旋股上面來看
可以這個類股來看
那另外一個旋股方式
我是從這個角度來看
我覺得這個蠻有趣的
就是股價
我們去把1000塊錢以上的50檔
好 1000塊以上 50千斤
那另外就是100到500人
這兩個我們是比較看好
主要原因是你看這兩個
這兩個的這個
最後的YY
是
成長幅度最大
一個是66、68、82
其實我們在買股票的時候
不是越便宜越好
其實現在這個AI的產業
進入一個本益比沒有封頂的概念
我記得以前我師傅告訴我說
你要買 turnaround story 的股票
其實就是本一名沒有封頂
本一名沒有封頂
意思就是說你把 P-Ration 再處理他的成長率
假設我現在 P-Ration 是 50 倍
我成長率是 100%
那我現在是 0.3
就是說用這樣的 沒有超過 1 以上
其實這個都算是合理
所以都是以這樣這兩個類股上來看
他加權的平均的 EPS 是 92.7
千元以上的
然後這個 100 到 500 是 13
然後他的 P-Ration 其實 100 到 500 其實是
P-Rex就蠻低的
等於說它是有機會
去成為未來的千金股
所以你在這樣的邏輯去看
你就是把財報整理完過後
然後再回過頭來
你去看一下它的估值
尤其估值在整個投資上面來看
是投資人最大的盲點
那你可能會買比較
你會覺得
因為我們常常碰到我們的客戶
會告訴我說
我現在是傳統產業
為什麼我的股價漲了上來
我的P值才15倍
那因為你沒有AI
就變成說有這樣子的一個情況
所以目前把這樣子的一個邏輯
跟各位觀眾好朋友做分享
我覺得應該就可以做一些選擇
好 前緣以上當然應該是法人盤
對不對
但是很令人驚喜的是
100塊到500塊錢的這一組
極具潛力
就像我們之前講說
有一些ETF在挑的時候
他不會挑台灣50了
他會挑可能前150裡面
有機會激進台灣50的
就是這樣的一個概念
光哥給我們很新的一些
啟發跟思考
今天非常謝謝光哥
我們現在要接下來做的事情
就請大家打開手上的股價圖
誰是100塊到500塊
覺得明明光哥講了那麼多
然後我們就回到說
到底誰是這一組
可是要搭配的就是
獲利年人的
還有所謂的PR
就是北一層當地的一個狀況